you know people love this it's good for
you right but this one looks like it's
giving me the thumbs up
is there a Jim Wang here
well this is Wayne Chang waitan he's a
new student and he's Chinese like you
he's gonna tag along to all of your
classes
accept math
he's way ahead of you in math I just
want to be a regular guy who does
regular stuff you made a new friend
I just thought this year was gonna be
different
[Music]
I may be able to help
what's going on I'm not from this world
I need your help with my quest to stop
the uprising
the gate between Earth and Heaven is
opening okay
you must stop it or everyone will perish
the fate of Your World hangs in the
balance I don't really see how I fit
into this whole thing from my guide
let me talk about something a little bit
cooler than guide servant yeah I know
you're right guys better
it will be difficult and dangerous maybe
the hero what if I'm not though
fate is not decided up there but down
here
so freaking unbelievable
everything is more connected than you
think
thank you